c'est non non
[Musique]
tout fout l'camp nos plus nobles
traditions se perdent
aujourd'hui par exemple on ne pourrait
même plus les présidents de la
république avant de les sortir
tu l'as dit bouffi et si on continue de
leur cirer les pompes
il y à belle lurette comme le relève
plus les pieds il y a deux siècles la
populace était bien plus respectueuse de
son souverain
je veux mon neveu savez vous qu en 1783
tenez vous bien tenez vous mieux merci
en 1783 avant de montrer un feu
d'artifice royal on allait jusqu'à
ignifuges et louis saez
[Musique]
ainsi le roi de france était totalement
inapplicable ça aurait été moins con
dignifier jeanne d'arc
etonnant non
[Musique]
fait étonnant non